acho bom a gente falar de matemática
biologia qualquer coisa a gente tem que
falar principalmente de códigos tudo nós
estamos falando aqui são códigos letras
são códigos
você junta algumas letras vão se tornar
palavras e quando você junta palavras
você começa a ter um fluxo de informação
exatamente sobre isso nós vamos falar
hoje sobre os fluxos de informação
existe um dogma central na comunicação
que me fala o seguinte toda a
comunicação tem um transmissor e um
receptor e para que essa informação
chegue de um receptor por um fã de um
transmissor receptor
ela passa por um canal e isso é bem
tranquila automaticamente sai de um
entra outro
mas nem toda forma de comunicação sempre
ocorre um problema sempre pode ter algum
tipo de ruído
imagina que não tipo de cidades dessas
ligações seja quando o transmissor manda
a sua informação pode acontecer um
pequeno problema no meio do caminho
imagina que sua tv e ph no dia de chuva
é a primeira coisa sair exatamente isso
que acontece
então quando você vai mandar sua
informação por outro receptor
esta informação chega truncada e seria
terrível
imagina você lá saindo de manhã coloca
seu cd de música sertaneja do seu carro
foi feliz da vida cantando no primeiro
buraco que você passa ele começa a pular
wazaká trava sua moto a música só de
engenharia elétrica fez um negócio muito
bacana eles começaram a pensar no fixo
félix mas um código que corrigiam isso
eles conseguiam ler a informação como um
todo e pegar esses bytes faltantes
conseguir corrigir ou seja ele conseguiu
fazer com que ela transmissão a
informação que saiu do transmissor até o
receptor chegasse de uma forma inteira
bom mas apresentava se com esse cara vai
falar sobre a evolução sobre biologia
dna que se tem a ver é a seguinte
informação sua informação genética todo
modificado
no dna o dna é uma coisa muito
interessante e tem a capacidade de se
auto replicar fazer a aplicação
todo esse dna ele é transcrito no rn a e
todo esse r é traduzido em uma proteína
os dados que você tem que você tá vendo
hoje aqui no meu organismo que você vê
de manhã quando é que o ocidente espelho
é função da proteína é sua pele seu
colagem tudo que você está vendo é a
proteína na biologia você também tem um
transmissor até chegar a um receptor
você pensar o seu rh pode ser um canal
só trabalhando então vamos ver como ter
um pouquinho de aula de matemática e
biologia para três mil tipos de dna
você consegue ter uma proteína você
consegue ter um aminoácido que foi de
códigos
a gente quer estudar se existe algum
tipo de correção designar se algum tipo
de fórmula matemática dentro de si
eu tenho que passar no meu universo
matemático universo biológico para o
universo matemático assim eu posso usar
um polinômios no qual vou usar um outro
lamento que eu vou dar 01 a 11 c e assim
sucessivamente
com isso eu tenho um sistema de
codificação eu vou quantificar na
sequência de dna numa seqüência ao jeca
eu passo do universo biológico para o
universo matemático aqui que entra a
coisa bacana quando você coloca nessa
parte matemática
se a matemática eu posso trabalhar com
os dados
trabalhando com esses dados eu posso
inserir sistema de corretores de erros
se eu quero fazer uma decodificação de
si no sistema
eu quero decodificar esse meu sistema do
universo matemático de volta pro
biológico se aplicar o código corretor
de erro
algumas vezes pode acontecer isso você
pega a mesma seqüência codifica
matematicamente de matemática biologia
com o corretor de erro acontece alguns
algumas mutações aparece nesse meio
aparece algumas no cotidiano
diferente do que eu tinha e canônico
nesse caso tem problema saiu já no
artigo com uma mesma
nossa mas pode acontecer eu tenho o meu
polônio decodificação codifica na hora
que eu volte a qualificação acontece uma
mutação
bom isso quando o pessoal da engenharia
elétrica mostrou pra gente responda em
alguma coisa e que não sabe o que
ocorreu a mutação que o que será que
pode ser bom
podemos acontecer passado uma cena eu
passar por um sistema de ns1 cobra de
parada que o código de parada é uma
informação codificada no nosso dna que
fala o seguinte olha você vai produzir a
proteína é aqui na hora que achar essas
seqüências
eu quero que você pare isso é importante
porque isso me fala o seguinte que essa
proteína
ela tem alguma coisa ou errada ou certa
errada é o que está funcionando hoje em
dia é certa o que está passado
não sei a gente pode ver isso pode ser
uma coisa bem interessante esse gene que
o código corretor de erro identificou
como tendo um stop corda no meio do
caminho ou seja que pararia essa
proteína proteína ligada às vezes a
receptividade à câncer de ovário e
conscientes e isso pode acontecer também
uma coisa que a gente começou a haver
bastante você tinha um aminoácido
triptofano sendo trocado por um stop
códon nossa isso é estranho porque toda
vez que vai corrigir tem um tributo
falando tem um só concordam que será que
aconteceu conhece como a literatura o
rapaz 1991 ele é de 97
ele viu que nos organismos mais
primordiais do sistema de parada é o
triptofano aí aquela luz
bom se tem um gene atuante hoje em dia
que pode causar algum problema como
exemplo a gente deu do câncer
eu tenho algumas pontos de paradas nas
minhas proteínas
eu tenho esse trabalho que fala que
antigamente triptofano um ponto de
parada
então pode começar a pensar em evolução
se eu pego revolução
qualquer dessas sequências propõe uma
filogenia e essa tecnologia é de arábia
italiana é maior desde o ginásio é uma
coisa bem interessante
eu não só peguei os cortes corrigidos
pelo erro eu forcei os erros na mesma
região por esses códigos
se a gente usa o sistema países e ana
tratar de datação dessas seqüências onde
eu quero saber a diferença entre a minha
seqüência canônica
na sequência atual como a sequência
antiga
se eu pego essa adaptação que está aqui
eu vejo que a seqüência do gerado pelo
código é pelo menos um milhão de anos
mais antiga do que a seqüência atual
esse é só um exemplo que a gente estava
dando a maioria dos dados que nós temos
é isso então vem algumas perguntas
começam a aparecer com esse é com esse
trabalho será que nós somos
então a nossa revolução ela é tão
aleatória
sim ela é aleatória se não tivesse
aleatoriedade nós não teríamos a grande
biodiversidade nós temos hoje em dia mas
as mutações dentro de um mesmo gene em
posições no seu dna
provavelmente não são tão aleatórios
assim você tem um código matemático
provando isso mostrando isso daí eu acho
interessante que as pessoas falam nós
vocês criar o código
então nós não criamos o código os
cientistas apenas olhar 11 efeito
natureza pensar nesse efeito natureza e
e demonstrar matematicamente porque a
nossa vida está aí a três bilhões de
anos
estou sendo com diversos a palavra tal
como essas pressões seletivas em cima
desse código mas apenas mostramos
matematicamente eo a mensagem que eu
gostaria que se levassem para casa eu
acho muito bacana
a mensagem do richard dawkins de 2009
que ele fala está fascinado de que a
genética é digital ou qualquer gene nada
mais é do que uma longa seqüência de
códigos
um programa de computador e que a
biologia moderna a se estudar biologia
moderna a se tornando cada vez mais um
ramo da tecnologia de informação
então a idéia é se nós temos que começar
a pensar a biologia como uma unidade
biológica ea biologia também como uma
unidade matemática que pode gerar erros
e pode corrigir os erros
essa era o que a gente era ideia era a
nossa ideia pra protege de hoje que os
levasse para casa
muito obrigada é uma boa tarde